bon alors on passe à la suite de
l'émission en face à l'hyper news
suivante mais en fait c'est une double
paire biwetz et je sais c'est très
nouveau
allez on existe deux personnes en même
temps avec deux personnes en même temps
c'est une double interview et nos
invités ce soir son arlette laguiller
françoise de panafieu
bonsoir
et ce avec elles venues ensemble parce
qu'elles semblent toutes les deux sur
leur 31 soit de panafieu bonsoir bonsoir
donc ce qu'on va faire je vous devant
vous interviewez séparément un quelques
questions comme ça un peu à chacune sur
votre ce que vous faites ce que vous
avez fait et ensuite on va passer à des
questions croisées sénat proposera les
mêmes questions à toutes les deux et on
verra comment vos réponses sont pose une
certaine foi se retrouvent fera quand
même dit aux téléspectateurs qui se
serait absenté trois minutes qu'on a
changé de sujet bon alors arlette
laguiller donc quand nous nous on se
connaît depuis 1987 deux-tiers venu dans
un bain de minuit et si une des
premières télés disons vous aviez fait à
parler les celles qui sont offertes aux
candidats des présidentielles voilà et
vous n'avez fait l'heure de vérité quand
donc c'est quand même huit ans après
bain de minuit c'était la première fois
que j'étais maquiller à l'heure de
vérité est là aujourd'hui vous êtes
maquiller oui oui ma qui est maintenant
pour la télé depuis 95 on m'a convaincu
que c'était mieux il sait mieux et c'est
mieux quand vous êtes pourquoi pourquoi
vous êtes là c'est que vous êtes
effectivement tout le monde en parle
parce que vous êtes crédité de 8 % aux
européennes par les derniers sondages
donc c'est beaucoup mais surtout il ya
45 % des français ça c'est dans
l'événement du jeudi cette semaine
45% des français qui approuvent arlette
laguiller ça veut dire qu'ils vont voter
pour arlette laguiller mais globalement
il l'a prouvé quand même atténuer un peu
mouvant partie jeu pourrait atténuer vos
propos c'est un peu flatteur vis-à-vis
dans les taillis et certes elle obtient
une douzaine d'écoles mes collègues je
voudrais rappeler qu elle a été
candidate en 74 à l'elysée à 80 88 ans
95 et là enfin obtenu 5% en 95
les mathématiciens ont calculé qu'à ce
rythme-là il pouvait être élu en 2000 97
fait les sciences exactes mais ça ne
tient pas compte du sentiment et des
réactions tout à fait lorsqu'il faut
dire aussi moi je vais continuer à être
flatteur ce qu'il faut dire aussi c'est
que vous êtes même numéro 14 dans la
liste des gens qui font le plus pour la
france
numéro 14 sur 60 millions de gens je
trouve c'est pas mal
alors cette porte parole justement ce
pas par hasard ont été choisis vous êtes
hors parole de lutte ouvrière en fait tu
t'ouvres hier c'est le nom du journal en
fait le parti s'appelle l'union
communiste
on dit beaucoup de choses vous savez on
dit beaucoup qui est connu sous le nom
de lutte oui beaucoup de choses depuis
1968 ouais je traduis pour rocco
siffredi curieux ouvrière
handicap en fonctionnement un
fonctionnement il est obligé de payer
les ardennes où je tombe dans l'extrême
aussi parfois par tirs un fonctionnement
secret quand même là d'autres parties un
fonctionnement secret si vous avez pas
parlé de ça voilà voilà
vous dites non pas du tout si je vous
allez vous allez ailleurs répété ces
ragots et chanteuse une auteur je suis
désolé car une fois secret gilles us
justement dans un journal que notre
journal lutte ouvrière a été déficitaire
mais pas du tout on se sent qu'il est
content de lui tout rires sont publiés
au journal officiel et entendu le patron
de votre parti qui s'appelle hardy
personne s'il n'ya pas trop à lui tout
seul il ya des camarades qui s'estiment
qui discutent entre eux qu'ils élisent
une direction qui désigne un porte
parole est plutôt une porte parole qui
est rare d'ailleurs parce que je vais
bientôt être la seule femme je crois
dans cette liste aux européennes a
dirigé une liste et c'est tout soir dit
par exemple qu'on le connaît pas nous
mais parce que vous vous connaissez pas
la moitié de notre direction c'est bien
parti secret c'est pas secrètes un parti
a quand même le droit de savoir et de
choisir par qui ils se faire représenter
et nous nous construisons un parti
principalement dans la classe ouvrière
de ce pays et nous voulons que nos
représentants
que ceux qui se font élire soit des
travailleurs durant parce que oui nous
pensions veut dire que monsieur aulas
ouvrière est capable de changer de
société
ce qui voudrait dire que monsieur hardy
n'est pas un travail on dit que c'est le
patron d'un laboratoire à la ce tic moi
qu'est ce que c'est que cet ex prises et
moi j'allais dire conneries je les
conneries
voir les cadres et vous savez bien vous
sentez comme chez vous savez très bien
sait très bien que c'est en toute la
presse relaie ce qui est triste pour la
profession de journaliste que ça a été
écrit une fois et c'est périodiquement
recollection alors j'espère qu'on les
aura les monarchistes richter que les
procès qui doit avoir lieu bientôt
contre tous ces journalistes accords
vont nous rendre justice d'accord bon
voilà ce qu'on peut dire pour finir de
vous présenter c'est votre partie basse
est le seul parti c'est trotskiste donc
ça jamais été essayé faut bien le dire
c'est votre chance c'est que quand on
vous parle de l'urss de la chine de cuba
du cambodge
vous dites que c'est pas des pays
communistes vraiment cédé pays stalinien
mais que c'est pas comme une différence
avec les autres et moi je ne dis pas
aujourd'hui 75 des gens freinent dire
aussi qu'elle a travaillée arlette
l'akita j'ai envie de vous appeler
renaître excusez moi elle a travaillé
dans une banque prendre combien de temps
mais depuis 56 à pendant 40 ans oui
depuis je suis en pré-retraite l'école
normale supérieure des institutrices et
les batteries comme mécanographe r j'ai
étudié son cas parce qu elle ne l a été
l ado crédit lyonnais il faut ni aux
crédits au secteur crédit immobilier
c'est vrai oui c'est vrai alors donc
vous aviez l'équipe qui venait vous voir
et qui vous disaient bonjour madame je
voudrais un prêt pour acheter un
appartement avec terrasse dans le xvième
qu'est-ce qu'on leur répondit les
travailleurs travailleuses
sa voix est étonnant j'avais pas le
pouvoir de dire oui ou de dire non
j'avais simplement à rentrer les
informations à monter les dossiers les
décisions se prenaient au dessus grandit
on dit que l' incendie du crédit
lyonnais c'est vous parce que ça faisait
ça faisait 30 ans vous réclamez un
cendrier depuis 74 la grève m'a brisé la
voie parce que pendant deux mois j'ai dû
parler beaucoup et après j'ai cessé de
fumer complètement en tout cas ça nous a
bien servi la banque parce que si elle
est aussi naturel devant les caméras
c'est parce que là bas ils
s'entraînaient il ya une caméra qui l'a
surveillé toute la journée au rejet de
sa vie sous les 14 une banque si elle ne
me prenez pas du pognon les clients sont
à surveiller aussi les clients puisque
les enfants d'abord
surveillez la ba oui c'est dommage ça a
été bien qu'ils aient la levée du secret
bancaire
pourquoi je me sens bien en tout cas
qu'elle n'ait pas changé depuis 74 pour
moi c'est toujours la même si elle est
restée aussi les maigres elle n'a pas
grossi
quand elle parle des gens qui ont faim
on y croit à côté de martine aubry vient
pas me refaire comme dj maf et fluette
passage a usé de gros progrès avant elle
avait toujours le même pull over mais là
regardez maintenant ça devient plus chic
au sein mais campagne électorale je
l'avais déjà yahoo à trois ans revient
avec vous c'est que vous êtes toujours
faut que ça change faut que ça change en
fait vous changez jamais cessé comme
france 3 et ça marche très bien en ce
moment
vous êtes financier vous trouviez
prochaine
sérieusement merci pour en finir avec
cette présentation dont votre père et ça
c'est justement comment se passent pas
fait exprès enfin savent à quel point
vous vous opposez à françoise de
panafieu votre père s'appelait louis
j'étais ouvrier enfin il a en commun
avec le père de françoise de panafieu
loyer était ouvrier était prisonnier de
guerre et mais le père de françoise de
panafieu était très proche du général de
gaulle donc là dessus vous pouvez pas
vous en prépa déjà il y aura pas de
discussion sur toi hitler staline
mosquées en france et quand même déjà ça
de gagné en france c'est la base de
toute discussion politique en général
votre mère s'appelait susan elle était
secrétaire j'ai vécu aux lilas dans un
tout petit appartement et il ya des
moments là sans vraiment tomber dans le
misérabilisme mais c'est vrai que dd
jour manger pour dîner du café au lait
avec du pain il n'y a pas d'électricité
donc c'est quand vous parlez la classe
ouvrière ce que je veux dire c'est que
vous l'avez vraiment connu que c'est pas
parce qu'on se rappelle plus que moi je
suis né en 40 qu'à la fin des années 40
début des années 50 on connaissait cette
misère on connaissait les sans domicile
fixe une règle du mej parents et les
frères da une pièce cuisine
il nous est arrivé des bergers trois
personnes qui autrement dormaient dans
la rue
donc oui j'ai connu j'ai connu tout ça
est chez je crois que j'ai eu conscience
assez vite des différences de classes
des inégalités mais je suis trop fit une
la présence de madame de panafieu et
vous avoir n'importe a le mérite de
journalistes on la donnait quelques
chèques
j'ai pas ma carte du rpr
pour finir pour finir à la tva ce coût
sera françoise de panafieu pour bien
vous n'êtes pas mariée à vous êtes ceni
cure énumère ses pas ni dieu ni maître
vous saignez cure énumère nous reprocher
il n'ya pas longtemps justement vous
êtes ici chez nous c'est vrai que c'est
curieux pour deux femmes politiques
comme ça qu'il passe derrière un sujet
avec rocco siffredi la vie et on vous a
justement reprochés et a pas longtemps
dans les aides aux télés votre
participation à une émission de tf1 y a
pas photo qui était consacrée aux riches
mais j'ai lu des tas de papiers ou
qu'est ce qu'elle fout là arlette
laguiller
alors est ce que vous craignez pas qu'on
dise la même chose ce soir pour cette
émission je m'en moque complètement
moi je dis ce que j'ai à dire où je peux
en 87 je pense que le plus gros est fait
depuis longtemps c'était fichu
attention après donc j'avais un petit
film porno ok on en parle à tout à
l'heure avec rocco il n'y a pas de
donner un repos de s'éloigner un peu
parce qu'ils commencent à me chatouiller
on parlera de romance tout à l'heure bon
alors avoue françoise de panafieu donc
nous on se connaît pas et on ne sait
jamais vu moi je vous ai vu à la
télévision bien évidemment donc fait une
entrée en force sur le marché des
futures mères de paris ça faut
reconnaître qu un sondage dans le jdd
nous étions peut-être de la droite
mérimée mais il ya eu donc pour les
municipales de 2001 bien évidemment
densité devant tiberi madelin et
balladur et à gauche c'était dsk
je me souviens plus du chef d'état
combien dans son âge c'était 60 % dont
l'effet des parisiens avant je ne peux
même plus vous dire le chiffre exact à
vrai dire je sais quand tous les cas
c'était un sondage que j'ai pas traité
avec désinvolture mais qui concernait
quand même 600 personnes
c'est à dire c'est tout de même pas la
terre entière d'accord mais enfin vous
étiez première d'autant plus qu'en 2001
c'est la mairie de paris l'ex ans pour
la mairie de paris x et un an avant la
présidentielle et que c'est quand même
ça va être assez important ne présentait
pas et une manif dans la capitale
municipal aux lilas si vous savez j'ai
pas sûr que ce soit le sujet de portée
nationalement je dirais pas que tout le
monde en parle certains aujourd'hui ça
va nous occuper ça va nous occuper plus
longtemps parce que de toute façon c'est
en 2001 et d'ici là où la voilà alors
qu'aujourd'hui présentement vous êtes
adjoint au maire pour les parcs et les
jardins alors si c'est vous qui avez
autorisé qu on aille flirter sur les
pelouse
eh oui
il est fourni en disposeraient comprend
un port la vie commence à faire beau et
chaque fois qu on s'allonge sur une
pelouse à roko françoise dubos histoire
encore bon c'est vous aussi parce
qu'avant les jardins les parcs et
jardins vous étiez la culture c'est lui
qui avait fait 18 francs 18 heures au
ciné voilà donc ça c'est bien aussi dans
tout ça a même fait démarrer des films
précédents qui étaient avec un démarrage
un peu difficile alors mis un petit coup
d'oeil ils appellent ça les petits que
de booster souvent faire les départs en
plus il est bas en plus c'est gratuit
j'y suis allé j'ai vu un film est rien
dès 18h 10 818 spectateurs s'étaient
trafic d'influencé alors donc vous êtes
ex-ministre du tourisme france fâché
avec tout le monde ici au gouvernement
au gouvernement juppé
ouais donc j'étais une jupette faut bien
se dire aujourd'hui avec jean pas dire
qu'on a sorti au printemps à la rentrée
voilà vous a été viré au casier l'unesco
quand même ou dans un nom sympa qui m'a
permis d'ailleurs comment marche
voilà un grand talent hors normes
internationales autre papa on parlait
tout à l'heure du du père d'arlette
laguiller dont vous c'est françois
missoffe qui est résistant de la
première heure donc encore une fois il
on sent comme un projet de gaulle carte
de l'umr numéro 01 donc là on peut pas
faire mieux que de break avec 0 0 on va
te perdre tes 0,1 et des ministres de la
jeunesse et des sports en 68 votre père
mon père il a été surtout il a suivi
pendant les dix ans
du gène quand le général était président
de la république
mon père a eu cette chance d'être l'un
de ses ministres pendant dix ans donc
pendant dix ans de sa vie il a côtoyé un
homme hors normes
alors votre maire là ça va beaucoup
choqué relais de la guinée je suis
désolé parce que là c'est tout ce que
vous n'aimez pas étudié très bien mais
je vis d'un même téléphoné c'est
complexe bon c'est encore hélène de
nutri dynastie wendel alors vous qui
l'avez toujours après les maîtres des
forges la cible et de lait devant vous
la représentante à la descendante de des
vandales voilà une branche wendel m
d'efforts tout est l'âme zola qui selon
ce qui peut expliquer que madame de
panafieu soit à droite témoin alex est
ce que justement on a utilisé sa classe
sociale possible c'est pas forcément y
est c'est vrai dit fils de bourgeois qui
ont un iphone afin d autres ils sont
engagés aux côtés de la soufrière pas je
puisse pas exactement le cas du rt est
très réussi leur faire ni partir du
missouri strié deux femmes comme ça en
face l'une de l'autre
je crois qu'elle s'entendre est
remarquablement malgré certaines
différences parce que je crois que ce
qui base la relation des gens c'est la
sincérité
or si arlette laguiller est une femme
que je crois profondément sincère dans
sa démarche
j'ai une mère qui est également d'une
intégrité d'une sincérité totale dans la
sienne vous mettez deux personnes de
qualité en face l'une de l'autre
quelles que soient leurs différences
elles se trouvent normal donc la
prochaine fois nous inviterons
il est très doué ou de la poudre est
très fort dans votre ville arlette mais
oui mais évidemment et parlaient tous
les avis de c'est pas bien
je ne sais pas faire les épinards et
donc alors retrouvé terminer votre
enfance bah oui disent oui ce n'est pas
de votre faute vous avez comme votre
père était ministre génère le vol de les
côtoyer chaban-delmas messmer debré
poniatowski bon mais je savais qu'à pire
oui j'ai très lié avec les enfants de se
dire que vous êtes ami avec jean louis
debré
nous sommes restés très curieusement les
enfants des ministres du général
nous sommes restés liés de manière
presque irrationnel c'était une vraie
famille moi j'aurais pu en profiter de
la présence de panafieu parce qu'elle
est à la mairie de paris et qu'elle nous
parle du maire de paris monsieur rocco
tiberi on l'appelle comme ça ils sont
dans des films x comme bavière j'ai
entendu dire quand même qu'il y avait un
projet si la place de la concorde était
piétonne de faire parce qu'il ya trop de
piétons place de la concorde
une circulation alternée des piétons que
jésus avoir un passe droit
ce qui chausse du 35 37 39 41 et 43 vous
allez remarquer les numéros impairs qui
ont une voiture
donc si on dirait numéro perdre 40 bis
un treuil marcheront les jours pairs il
paraît qu roland dumas qu'un pied plus
d'europe circuleraient librement tous
les jours
question j'ai faits de violences et de
pillages la rive droite c'est tous les
jours tous les jours ça me va très bien
tous les jours bon pour terminer et
encore une fois se bat pour vous opposer
mais c'est comme ça vous n'êtes pas
mariée en toque quand même vous avez
encore mais c'est bizarre comme c'est
vrai comme déjà problème d'origine
évident et alors vous vous n'êtes pas
mariée tout ça vous n'êtes pas d'enfant
vous et huit enfants
vous avez quand même un an vous étiez
sûr de vous avez des buts en huit
minutes huit enfants et vous en mettre 4
vous n'êtes que kaba c est votre mari
quitte panafieu donc elle président de
bulles louis sociétés ont directement
voilà donc vous voilà à présenter
maintenant je vous dis là à notre vie
alors maintenant on va maintenant on va
vous faire réagir sur des sur des sujets
précis brièvement je vous le demande à
toutes les deux un brièvement d'un peu
du coq à l'âne comme ça va passer d'un
sujet grave des fois un sujet pas grave
on va commencer avec vous à l'atelier
vous écrivez quoi quand on vous demande
un autographe ou non mais c'est que vous
mettez quoi ça dépend ça dépense c'est
quelqu'un de proche quelqu'un qui dans
l'émission vous demande une auto pas
vous écrivez quoi vive la révolution
signé relais tout oui c'est possible oui
ça peut arriver ici j'ai le temps de
parler un peu de pluie pour voir s'ils
achetaient une livre particulier
j'aimerais leur parole de prolétaires
camarades voilà je le montre à la caméra
voilà donc la cdc lourd j'ai toutes mes
dents ça c'est la vida relativement bas
qu'ils disent et le titre vous françoise
de panafieu même question on vous
demande des autographes pour vous
écrivez quoi elle signalé cela qui est
le prénom de la personne souvent jeu
mais son prénom sur tout et je mets mon
nom à moi c'est oui si vous y tenez pas
une petite
pas fort si je ne connais pas la
personne c'est qu'ils demandent alors
autre question pour vous maintenant la
parité vieux thème dieu est amour voilà
vous mettez ça vous allez
comme j'en suis mais deux le matin deux
le soir comme c'est trop fort comme truc
que les gens ils pensent bien le matin
et le soir
la parité hommes-femmes est ce que vous
trouvez que c'est bien parce que c'est
bien de protéger les femmes comme comme
une espèce qui met devraient être
protégés écoutez je partirai courant
d'idées cas pas besoin de quotas pour
que d'abord mon courant il est
représenté par une femme plus dans les
élections qui viennent il y a sur les
dix premiers de la liste lui femmes ce
qui veut dire que si nous avons des élus
à part notre camarade alain krivine qui
est en deuxième position derrière moi la
majeur est la parité pour vous comme ça
il ya je crois sur la ligue 45 femmes et
42 sommes donc ça cela dit bon je
comprends que dans certains partis les
femmes se battent pour ses trajets jeune
françoise la parité pourquoi porter je
suis député à l'assemblée nationale donc
tout à fait différent donc la venue on a
eu vraiment à se prononcer vous sur ce
projet de loi est au début quand on m'a
parlé de la parité j'ai trouvé la
première fois il ya deux ans que j'ai
entendu ce mot comme possible de
l'inscrire dans notre constitution j'ai
été très choqué et puis au bout du
compte je me suis dit d'abord nous
n'étions pas une espèce comme vous le
dites mais que nous sommes la moitié du
genre de l'humanité et que deuxièmement
et que deuxièmement mais vous n'êtes pas
mal non plus les conditionnements
les blues
on attendait il faut vous en remettre un
aussi le droit de donner notre avis bien
sûr et qu'en 1947 nous étions 5 17% à
l'assemblée nationale est qu'aujourd'hui
nous avions été au lendemain des
élections législatives dernières
journées donc vous pensez que je suis
dit qu'est-ce qui est le plus humiliant
pour une femme
est ce que c'est d'avoir en passer par
la parité ou est ce que c'est de rester
indéfiniment à 5,7 pour cent de la
représentation nationale est passé sans
état d'âme que j'ai choisi de voter pour
la parité mais voilà vous avez répondu
ils n'ont rien et on dîne de jean
giraudoux c'est aussi là la femme
préférant personnages préférés elle dit
au cheval yorn ça lui dit mais est-ce
que c'est trop de demandes et de te dire
que tu m'aimes alors lui dire je t'aime
et elle dit mais décrit moi mes
victoires tu renonces acquis pour moi et
il n'y a rien presque rien toutes les
femmes dit les impurs laisse les
excitante les moustaches et deux avis
toutes les femmes et elle se reprend
dîner elle dit aux hans
je voudrais offrir l'univers et voici
que je n'en retire la plus belle moitié
avec ses 26 cm
ses yeux brillent express et avec ma
langue je pense que gardoise de pain
d'épicés martigues à un dilemme
messieurs vous tiendra au courant du
développement
je ferai un commentaire or direct de
l'évolution de la situation ici bon jean
marie bigard mais vous connaissez le
prix d'un ticket de métro bout
non j'ai bien peur que non je suis
scooter mais parlait depuis deux ans que
je travaille plus je sais plus alors
j'avais la carte orange avec giscard
qu'ils savaient et le pire c'est que nos
discussions c'est pas moi je prends le
rer le faire il ya dans ce mauvais que
giscard d'estaing qui ne laissait pas le
prix du ticket de métro maintenant je
m'aperçois que c'est lé francs 85 francs
son coût du risque c'est un peu plus
cher qu'il ya le guette ainsi c'est au
carnet ventes privées voilà c'est comme
d'hab c'est ce à quoi bon arlette
laguiller aurait par une carte question
comme ça un commerçant se trompe en vous
rendant la mener vous lui dites il vous
donnera en cendres plus vous voyez est
ce que vous lui dise à nous aussi de ne
plus ou moins longue
bien sûr j'y donne lui aussi d'une
piscine le monde quelle va être la
réponse oui j'ai un bar avec les enfants
c'est pas juste un an
j'y tiens ou petits commerçants de mon
quartier parce que quand vous lui la vie
est difficile dans les quartiers
populaires et saccagé une animation
manger les vaches ont cherché chez
fauchon alors là je les garde
ces solutions chez tati j'ai besoin de
moi là je vais sur ma circonscription
fait pas car c'est facile moi non moi
j'ai un gros défaut
en face et aussi peut-être une qualité
je n'aime pas je fais confiance et je me
rends compte en écoutant votre question
que c'est rare sauf si je donne un gros
billet mais ça m'arrive enrichissement
de vérifier je retombe pas en fait je
fais je fais confiance à celui qui me
rend la monnaie
ouais c'est curieux je ne sais pas ce
réflexe de recompter mes pièces bah oui
quand c'est des fois sans le vouloir on
peut voler des commerçants
la prochaine fois je lui montrais puces
a relaté ce que vous êtes pour la taxe
tobin sa taxe personne souffle moi je
suis pour prendre sur les profits des
grandes entreprises pour créer des
enfants alors qu'ils veulent en savoir
si françoise je le voyais plus veut le
moins bobine
je ne suis pas forcément contre la taxe
tobin chipeau je suis en gros pour taxer
les placements spéculatifs et vous
foncerez plugin il ment à tout petits
qui demande tout petit quand soit de
panafieu non j'ai pas d'idée
la circulation des bus quelle idée
absolument géniale c'est les gens du
monde diplomatique et on parle très bien
il ay demande contactez toutes les
transactions d'argent de 1%
et si on arrivait tout tout tout
l'argent qui circule toute la journée
dans le monde c'est ce qui fait tout le
temps dès que l'argent bouge on en prend
oui mais c'est pas comprendre qu'il veut
ça permettrait d'éradiquer le tombeau
d'un saint
j'y croyais pas sur la spéculation sur
la spéculation sur une talonnade une
bourse à l'autre pour spéculer qui fait
que des économies s'écroulent comme en
ce moment au brésil ou en asie
bon alors je crois que ça règlerait pas
le problème de la spéculation mais si le
concurrent hilton demander une taxe
supplémentaire sur l'argent sur le
profit sur ce qu'ils gagnent concurrence
de façon de faire la révolution la taxe
tobin nom où ça suffirait pas ça suive
pas évidemment nous le savez très bien
d'ailleurs
bah quand même à ça je sais pas les
chiffres parce que ça vous le savez très
dire je le sais très bien dit le jeune
fille demande pardon révolutionnaire les
textes des vrais oui enfin tobin séparer
policiers à leur union est conseillé de
kennedy prix nobel pour ses travaux sur
les fonds spéculatifs thani c'est
quelqu'un qui cherche un petit peu à
limer les ongles du capitalisme parce
que il ya même des capitalistes qui se
rendent compte que la chaîne téva
patrice evra vous et combien d'argent
sur vous arlette je sais pas où dans la
loge si vous l'avez laissée dans la
logique si vous la laissez là qu'elle
savait plus rien 4 300 francs est-ce que
vous pouvez nous les donner maintenant
les bosquets du pognon il ya un truc
même qui est très clair le pognon le
chômage mais je suis content de parler
avec deux représentantes comme ça
charmant de la politique ou du
gouvernement tout ça parce que le pognon
faut quand même expliqué un jour aux
gens que les les
les gens riches sont de moins en moins
sans plus en plus riches et de moins en
moins nombreux c'est une pyramide et
bien que les pauvres ils sont de plus en
plus beau et de plus en plus nombreux et
que ça c'est un truc logique de me
demande si je suis choqué non ce qu'on
fait avec 200 francs et gens qui le font
avec 200 vidéos tout simplement et puis
du chômage fait arrêter faut dire aux
gens il y aura pas de moins en moins de
chômage aura de plus en plus de ce
journal chaque fois car une machine qui
sera pas syndiqués qui pourrait qu'ils
gueulent rappaz qui travaillera jour et
nuit
en fermant sa gueule en travaillant
mieux que 10 personnes qui quittent qui
frappe il y aura toujours il y aura de
plus en plus de chômage c'est ça c'est
pour ça que si on devait lui offrir
non mais voilà ça y est vous à ludique
et on marque en ville que dans mes mots
non moi mon truc c'est bien d'aider même
si dans son quartier en se prenait si
nous la autour de cette table on se
prenait chacun quatre ou cinq clodo qui
sont dans la rue on règlerait le
problème d'ailleurs les entreprises qui
ne sont pas gouvernementale et qui donne
l'exemple comme par exemple les restos
du coeur sont des gens qui donnent
gratuitement de leur temps pour les
autres c'est ce qu'on attend de tous les
élus c'est qu'il ne soit pas au service
de leurs propres intérêts mais au
service jusqu'au vote des autres et ça
on ne peut pas l'institutionnaliser
c'est pour ça que les restos c'est des
gens qui pillent tu ne gagnes pas de
fric et qui viennent aider les autres
institutionnalisée suffit pas non mais
si j'ai un formidable lorsque les le
nombre de repas aux restos du coeur ils
augmentent chaque année c'est pas une
solution
les pauvres les chômeurs de cette
solution et à l'arrivée avant le g7 usa
je l'aï mise en ouvre l'ère de la
chapeauter chacun soit un emploi
salaires vie normal que je ne sais pas
ce que je propose c'est que si on veut
changer le monde il faut changer d'abord
soit c'est john lennon c'est ça qui font
rimer savez
trois mille ont fait changer moi faut
changer chaque fois qu'on incitera les
gens à s'occuper de leur prochain c'est
pour ça que moi je suis plus dans
l'équipe dans les jambes et je que de
soutenir jean marie c'est que je pense
que j avais bien sûr il y en a je suis
convaincu vous en avez que je vais
mouiller la chemise bien vu
bien sûr j'en suis convaincue mais
seulement l'ennui c'est 200 syfy
maîtrise jumelles oui mais l'ennui c'est
qu'il y en a trop con taper dans la
caisse et maintenant on peut plus les
reconnaître ceux qui sont vraiment
gentils de ceux qui sont pas tout à fait
gentil et ça c'est un gros problème
entre par parler de mon film là c'est
trop tôt au cou qui s'impatientent je
sais pas je vais pas tenir si longtemps
relisons vous nous donnez une passé
quelque chose à toutes les deux avant de
parler avant de passer le taux de chô
passionnément macho quant au chaud
il m'avait s'écoute digard je lui
donnais cuillère j'ai eu envie de faire
ce qu'ils nous disent qu'ils veulent je
suis d'accord pour le faire mais
d'accord mesdames et messieurs ce assez
macho non ça c'est pas macho parce que
ça c'est mon grand frère qui me faisait
ça regardez bien il pas d'une cuillère
comme ça c'est le moment le plus regardé
à regarder dans les cuillères d'ouvriers
dans les cuillères c'est le plus beau et
qui sinue kislev les frais d'une cuvette
je dédie à ses rêves leurs lauriers
regardez la cuillère ça marche très bien
ça marche ça marche voyez vous voyez là
on voit les fesses et puis là les bras
croisés à mon grand père me faisait ça y
est tous les gosses à la cantine vont
faire ça à partir de
tout à leur enlèvement
passé avant de passer aux options est ce
que vous arrivez par exemple de changer
de look est ce que par exemple
moi j'ai un truc pour vous laisse que
vous mettriez est-ce qu'on peut venir
avec la veste pour arlette laguiller
c'est pas quelque chose de choquant
simplement c'est une tenue dans laquelle
on vous a rarement vu c'est une veste
chanel c'est le modèle aussi moche c'est
gentil
à l'egypte à mèche c'est cher dans les
airs de vos données contre les autres
françoise de panafieu je dois me
l'enlever tout de suite vous la mettez
c'est pourquoi france lemaitre vêtements
non
bah moi je mets en garde l alizé satin
rose et habillez vous êtes en train de
vous n'êtes pas le mec c'est simone veil
quand ma main ah bon mais chacun son
sein de gaulle et dire mais si on peut
apporter la neige attendue
vous allez vous avez reçue de
l'assemblée zazie factor hier grossi
ferry qui dit moi je veux pas prendre
les vestes mais les filles qui les amène
non moi je vais faire pour vous mais
l'inversé par exemple ça marchera pas
non plus se sauve les pas du blues en
ont plus à rennes on a regardé royal et
voilà à dix on veut donner l'exemple et
100 m je me tapais on n'en parle plus je
vais mettre des allées de néons tentant
but vous entendu
question
oui je m'habille parler
je mets la deuxième
en plus moi je suis à billom julien
lepers pour enrc heure là les enfants
très datation je ne crois pas vous
refuser une belle chanel c'est votre
droit mais alors accepté c'est vraiment
une guest
c'est une baisse de julien lepers pas
quoi je alors ce qu'on va faire
maintenant parce que c'est parti pour
gilles bien le faire alors vraiment pas
bien je viens à julien près n'importe
quoi bon vous savez qui est une
tradition dans cette émission c'est bien
mais où la bulle est en train de marquer
des points
5 n'est pas tête de liste aux
européennes dont la part est alors
justement ya bien une
au fond il
ouais comme quoi l'habit fait le moine
parce que ça va se terminer
françoise de panafieu ou tard joey starr
et arlette sérieux dans cette émission
une tradition c'est qu'on chante
l'internationale robert hue la chanter
je lui chanter avec lui daniel cohn
bendit l'a chantée est ce que vous êtes
d'accord pour chanter le couple et de
l'international que vous préférez les
liens je suis là non non non non moi je
connais pas mais je la connais non à ben
ali à 2,3 c'est la lutte finale
groupon nous demain
tant mieux pour moi